[Music]
in fake facts news defects Thanks
swimming by Joe moly an entree
Oh what would that be mouse nuggets
what mouse nuggets
oh that sounds pretty good well the
tails still attached you like chicken
those little tails yeah because you've
seen their handles I had rats too but
I'll still eat it no morals no and
they're expensive I will never eat a dog
dogs are like cows in India India Mallya
that they are royalty here 14 widely
believed facts that are absolutely
untrue
Oh for real I just found one out and
this kind of mess that might miss my
childhood I was just like wow mom why'd
you do that for me yes out of clauses a
liver he was a real man though oh yeah
it's saint class Nicholas the one was so
whenever we would be driving at night I
would turn on the light yeah I know moms
like turn that thing off Ross print that
the cops are gonna give me a ticket and
just like this year I found out that
that's not true you know it's funny
that's not that's not illegal no oh yeah
theme cuz I thought it's all Isaac - you
think really why is it illegal and I'm
like good question how did you find that
out I think it was on I think it was
like on IG or something were there like
my life has changed forever and then it
was like it's not illegal and it looked
it up and I'm like why mom why she
doesn't wanna argue with you anymore if
you say something's against a lot of
kids like gosh yeah yeah yeah right
yeah cuz my parents would say that it
bothers the other drivers so don't do it
so then when I finally had a car I
turned it on and I walked and I looked
at it and I was like it'll bother nobody
you see other cars that with it on at
night I'm like oh dude they're gonna get
it
or like you would think cuz like you
know we've all driven with our brights
on and you've had people to update your
brights on you like they like do this
thing like you would think that people
would drive up to you be like your
indoor lights on your [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] like what nobody cares nobody cares
why would they care I'm not that smart
okay I couldn't put two and two together
I said what are these facts that that
are actually wrong facts like because it
feels like everything in politics and
everything that we get [ __ ] fed in
the news is that exactly - son I'm broke
well you see that my head is the middle
of the W and then the hands is like you
just look like a fox or a squirrel or
something years did you make that up
Rizzo no I made this [ __ ]
that's cool whoa you're like a moose
yeah well cuz then it goes yeah the
thumbs go in your beef you get more you
go like well like the more annoying it
gets which is really good well you gotta
start with this cuz it's a W you're
making me want to watch them I want to
watch the news and just eat everything
they're spitting in my mouth it's true
you are literally becoming more and more
like Bobby Lee
why slept King yeah now you're the woke
moose slept King in the nog he's just
trying to copy me I was a king before he
ever was oh well you're a moose now yeah
you're not a king no more only when I'm
woke the energy of a moose okay a lot of
these back pretty sure you guys known
that they're not true I know I hope you
don't [ __ ] up my the rest of my life
Tiffani number one talking on your cell
phone will give you cancer it's false I
knew it I never believed it I never
believed it yes I did
zero evidence supporting the link
between cell phones and malignancies I
do believe it a little bit cuz when I go
to sleep at night I put that cell phone
like away from my head cuz I just felt
like there's like some sort of like I
don't know electromagnetic force now you
can sleep with it on your head like
you've always wanted
and I keep it with my ballsack - I'm so
happy the begin of your ballsack number
two holding your laptop on your lap will
make you sterile that's all never heard
that thank God I did it for so long I
have a shot now how about the energy to
eating carrots makes you orange what I
heard it improves your eyesight that's
false for sure I don't know hey wait
carrots don't improve your vision no I
think you're full of [ __ ] I think just
about to expose you watch this [ __ ]
hey tip take it away yes no under
certain conditions eating carrots will
help improve I thought it soon I didn't
say that though that was Gio so you told
me I'm [ __ ] get your fake news out
of here pal your ass I said carrots make
you all ready I'll get your [ __ ] out of
here carry the buck you live I've had
really bad eyes my whole life and I
asked like multiple Hamish about that
and they're like whatever the positive
effect is to help your eyes it's very
but not it doesn't make any [ __ ]
difference
thank you so yeah oh damn I gots like in
like conjunction with something else the
point is it does help well the point is
we're both ways we're both right I don't
like that okay it's either I don't like
having mutual I'm pretty sure David's
right cuz if you stare cross-eyed at a
TV doesn't matter how many [ __ ]
character you get oh I know another
false thing that my parent used to do
they would say don't sit close to the TV
or else you're gonna go blind actually
that helps you on the couch that was all
here I'm like oh don't worry yeah cuz
when you strain your stretches and I'm
on make some myopic and then you start
getting your side oh my god everything's
a joke everything's a [ __ ] lie
yeah that's insane came up with that
[ __ ] your mom did another lies what
I mean
you're supposed to watch these what is
super comfortable to your eyes yeah yeah
and I would I'm like I can't see and
somehow like I think you know as a kid
like you're playing and you don't
realize how like you end up where you're
at and I would be like right here again
yeah that's what they have recommended
TV sizes for your living room your
living rooms this big for every one of
you a comforter you should actually get
it this size they make different sizes
for that reason for your eyeballs and my
grandma told me that too yeah my mom
could have kept me still or anywhere in
one place how about this on it we still
can you never heard this one before but
number eight on this list eating
watermelon seeds will give you a pen
decided I've ever heard I thought as a
kid never heard of that no one told me
this but I thought as a kid when I eat
it then a watermelon did you get the
rose Rugrats cuz that's where I got it
from oh maybe I did too you made that up
in your own head that's right Chuck
needs one right yeah because what do you
do with you with seeds you plant them in
your [ __ ] them out what no I mean that's
a kid when you plant a seed you're
planting it so that something grows yeah
but I also read a lot of books
there's no about how birds would eat
seeds and they would that's how they
plant stuff so that's how I knew it
wasn't true when I was a kid how so I
didn't read okay David when I was a kid
I'm so [ __ ] stupid that I swallowed a
bell to see if I could hear it when I
jumped out yeah and I told my mom and
she freaked out and they called the CDC
halt [ __ ] if you had to puke it out or
what glad to make sure that I got it out
of my system and when you get hooked
inside how did they get it out they
either give me like some kind of [ __ ]
did that also was it like the what kind
of Bell like a Christmas [ __ ] out a
little bit like a cat I was like
probably 17 no no I was like [ __ ]
Isla no like six seven years old it was
like this big no it's like this that
hurts out of your butt I'd like the ones
that are on stockings and that made a
jingle sound and so and I watched Bugs
Bunny [ __ ] all the time so I wanted to
see if I could hear it inside my body
did you hear it John's [ __ ] were you
able to no [ __ ] no I couldn't hear [ __ ]
I was like it doesn't work I was pissed
I told my mom I was like it doesn't even
work and she's like oh my god Charles
Chuck we got Chuck we got Stephen
Stephen did some [ __ ] did you get a
[ __ ] blanket and try to parachute
from like your [ __ ] oh of course I
did that yeah well we had bumpers
everybody did that
not prey on your nose no I didn't do
that now a stupid stupid I was dominant
a lot of dumb [ __ ] too though like
remember when Cutco knives are super
popular and the miracle blade so I
remember we got a miracle blade and I
was like cool I'm a slice is pineapple
like they always do on TV so like that
yep so what happened was I sliced my
hand oh good thing you still have to
have you told us that happened to you
recently no I cut my hands for regular
ship now another one if the jellyfish
things you urine will help believe you
at the pain that's false you should be
using vinegar that's a good prank then
because a lot of people getting peed on
why right now yeah wait does your is
your pace your pace is your pay acidic
or was it basic basic or acidic carnal
but it smells like [ __ ] it's clear all
clear
have you heard of crossing your legs
will give you varicose veins no you get
that [ __ ] cuz you old yeah well you get
that [ __ ] because if you stand a lot
you're the blood pools and your legs and
then the veins
getting large really yeah so don't stand
up I don't stand much sitting more but
that should kill you guys get so you
like yeah everybody your life yeah but
somebody told me that women are more
prone to it women have higher body fat
and it's because something had to do
like testosterone or some like that like
testosterone prevents it or some [ __ ]
possibly but yeah but good is not more
fatty tissue what else is there to thank
you know I'm really [ __ ] curious
because I'm not yeah this is cool I
don't want to be ignorant okay so listen
much how to be Dignan you should wash
your chicken before cooking it [ __ ] that
I cooked that [ __ ] right away
Jess I know you're watching this tell me
the detail so it says you should not
wash your chicken before cooking you do
that [ __ ] Jeff I talk about whole
chickens or chicken breasts crotch
just raw chicken because because the
splashes of the water could potentially
oh no that's what she told me she's
right how right you were she was right
so if you're washing your chicken and
then all the splashes it'll have these
germs that can spread a little to cook
that [ __ ]
no no because that's done that depends
on the application of how you're cooking
it dude because if you're making a stock
and you're not washing your chicken on
whatever nerves
[ __ ] behind no no we're not talking
about germs but we're talking about what
you're cooking so if you're not if
you're making a stock right and you have
a chicken carcass there's all that blood
and scum you got to watch that [ __ ] out
before you put into your stock because
then you have this come that [ __ ] off
later on it's done oh yeah listen to
David he knows yeah what people buy
chicken bullion don't even put it on a
cutting board and cut that [ __ ] cuz
you're just spreading [ __ ] jerk yeah I
think that these are faster like 99% of
the time but then if you have like a
professional chef then it doesn't matter
no okay next one brown eggs are better
for you than white ain't that's false
nobody thinks that there is zero
difference in the nutrition what's the
point of these [ __ ] brown eggs it's
just the greatest we didn't wheat wheat
bread in our white bread well there's a
big big difference we better there's
literally no that's why that's probably
why they thought that so what are the
point of those these guys are it's just
different breeds of chicken you know
what is the good one though it was way
below the window yeah or the yolk is
really deep orange yeah but that's weird
for us here because we're not used to it
I like that [ __ ] though the eggs would
[ __ ] it better yeah yeah when people
from other countries come here they're
like this shit's weird there's some
funny yo did you have eggs and Friends
though that [ __ ] was bomb as [ __ ] you
check out the rest in the link in the
description okay quickly I'll take it
[Music]